good afternoon
I want to thank with steena for inviting
me and Joey for that incredible
introduction I feel like we're done here
where should we go and mostly I'd like
to thank you all for coming
voilá
well today as you know is the funeral of
Freddie gray and so I thought I would
start with the piece my brothers are
notorious they have not been to prison
they have been imprisoned the prison is
not a place you enter it is no place my
brothers are notorious they do regular
things like wait on my birthday they say
my name they will never forget that we
are named what is that memory the days
of our childhood together were steep
steps into a collapsing mind it looked
like we rescued ourselves were rescued
then there are these days each day of
our adult lives they will never forget
our way through these brothers each
brother and my brother dear brother my
dearest brothers dear heart your hearts
are broken this is not a secret though
there are secrets and as yet I do not
understand how my own sorrow has turned
into my brother's hearts the hearts of
my brothers are broken if I knew another
way to be I would call up a brother I
would hear myself saying my brother dear
brother my dearest brothers dear heart
on the tip of a tongue one note
following another is another path
another dawn where the pink sky is the
bloodshot of struck of sleepless of
sorry of
senseless shush those years of and
before me and my brothers the years of
passage plantation migration of Jim Crow
segregation of poverty inner cities
profiling of one in three two jobs boy
hey boy each a felony accumulate into
the hours inside our lies where we are
all caught hanging the rope inside us
the tree inside us its roots are limbs a
throat slice through and when we open
our mouth to speak blossoms oh blossoms
no place coming out brother dear brother
that kind of blue the sky is the silence
of brothers all the days leading up to
my call if I called I'd say goodbye
before I broke the goodbye I say goodbye
before anyone can hang up don't hang up
my brother hangs up though he's there I
keep talking the talk keeps him there
the sky is blue that kind of blue the
day is hot is a cold are you cold
it does get cool are you cool are you
cool
my brother is completed by sky the sky
is his silence eventually he says it is
raining it is raining down it was
raining it stopped raining
it is raining down he won't hang up he's
there he's there but he's hung up though
he's there goodbye I say I break the
goodbye I say goodbye before anyone can
hang up don't hang up wait with me wait
with me though the waiting might be the
call of goodbyes
in the book I'm going to try something
I'm going to integrate in the book that
that piece is followed by this image
this was the most difficult image to get
for the book when I approached the
Fulton archives through Getty they said
no they said we're afraid of what people
would use this for image for and so they
refused so we did that thing where you
wait a few days and hope you get
somebody else on the phone so we called
back and we did get somebody else on the
phone and she said well can you send the
text and we sent her the tax and then
they said yes but after all that I was
very nervous because I actually wanted
this so I approached them again and I
said do you mind if we take the bodies
out and they're like sure no problem
because they didn't want the scandal of
that photograph to create a replicated
moment so the removal of the scandal
just left the construction of whiteness
that is implicated in systemic racism
and they were okay with that
so that that's the photo that is in the
text I I live in Southern California and
just blocks from my house it's a
mountain range and I walk up that
mountain rage most days when I'm home
with my dog Sammy and
I have a friend who often walks with me
and so I said to her one day can you
describe to me a moment when you know
what you're doing you're doing because
you were white and it's about an hour up
and for an hour she gave me thoughts and
I was like I don't know
and finally on our way down she said
well you know I think I'm having a
difficulty because I don't do this
here in California because it's a car
culture but when I'm on the East Coast
and I'm on public transportation and I
see that seat next to a black man empty
I sit in it and so I said to her well I
do the same thing so does that mean I'm
a white woman too I don't know but we
had a very interesting discussion about
what it means to recognize a break in
American society and how you then
address it you know obviously you vote
but then you also put your body in that
place on the train the woman standing
makes you understand there are no seats
available and in fact there is one is
the woman getting off in the next stop
no she would rather stand all the way to
Union Station the space next to the man
is the pause in a conversation you are
suddenly rushing to fill you step
quickly over the woman's fear a fear she
shares you let her have it the man
doesn't acknowledge you as you sit down
because the man knows more about the
unoccupied seat than you do for him you
imagine it is more like breath than
wonder he has had to think about it so
much you wouldn't call it
when another passenger leaves his seat
and the standing woman sits you glance
over at the man he's gazing out the
window into what looks like darkness you
sit next to the man on the train bus in
the plane waiting room anywhere he could
be forsaken you put your body there in
proximity to adjacent to alongside you
don't speak unless you are spoken to and
your body speaks to the space you feel
and you keep trying to fill it except
the space belongs to the body of the man
next to you not to you where he goes the
space follows him if the man left his
seed before Union Station you would
simply be a person in a seat on the
train you would cease to struggle
against the unoccupied seat when where
why the space won't lose its meaning you
imagine if the man spoke to you he would
say it's okay I'm okay you don't need to
sit here you don't need to sit and you
sit and look past him
into the darkness the train is moving
through a tunnel all the while the
darkness allows you to look at him does
he feel you looking at him you suspect
so what does suspicion mean what does
suspicion do the soft gray green of your
cotton coat touches the sleeve of him
you are shoulder to shoulder those
standing you could feel shadowed you sit
to repair whom who you erase that
thought and it might be too late for
that
it might forever be too late or too
early the train moves too fast for your
eyes to adjust to Evan anything beyond
the man the window the tile tunnel it's
slick darkness occasionally a white
light flickers by like a display sound
from across the aisle tracks room
harbour world a woman asked a man in the
rows ahead if he would mind switching
seats she wishes to sit with her
daughter or son you hear but you don't
hear you can't see it's then the man
next to you turns to you and as if from
inside your own head you agree that if
anyone asks you to move you'll tell them
we are travelling as a family I was um
discussing that peace with Lauren Boland
and she said to me why are you positing
the family is some kind of solution to
this and and I fear she's right but it
was one of those moments where because
it happened I thought well it didn't
happen which you know is no there's no
reason for anything but I feel it's my
duty to erase the ending even as I speak
it the other question I asked a friend
of mine he's a lawyer
he lives in Southern California and he
grew up he actually grew up across the
street from Paul Newman he's actually
told me some really interesting stories
one of them being that Paul Newman
actually brought over the vinaigrette to
be tasted
what do you think and so another he told
me another fascinating story where he
they had a gardener who was undocumented
and one day my friend went outside and
he said to him just don't cut the grass
today because he he was ten and he
wanted to see what would happen if you
didn't cut the grass they would grow
more I guess but he you know he was
tense so the garden assumed they meant
he was fired so he never came back um
anyway that's where he loved and grew up
so I asked him I said if I make you a
meal will you come to my house and tell
me every single time you've been pulled
over by the police every story that you
hold so he said yes and he came over
with his wife his wife is white and and
she had never heard any of these stories
which was surprising and not surprising
I mean some of them
he'd been pulled over with her in the
car but the more gruesome ones happened
with him in the car on his own
actually he was recently pulled over
with his two boys and in the backseat
Isaiah said oh are we going to prison I
knew whatever was in front of me was
happening and then the police vehicle
came to a screeching halt in front of me
like they were setting up a blockade
everywhere were flashes a siren sounding
and a stretched-out roar get on the
ground get on the ground now then I just
knew and you're not the guy and still
you fit the description because there is
only one guy who was always the guy
fitting the description
I left my clients house knowing I would
be pulled over I knew I just knew I
opened my briefcase on the passenger
seat just so they could see yes officer
rolled around on my tongue which grew
out of a bell that could never ring
because it's emergency was a tolling I
was meant to swallow in a landscape
drawn from an ocean bed
you can't drive yourself sane so angry
you are crying
you can't drive yourself sane this
motion where's a guy out our motion is
wearing you out and still you're not
that guy then flashes a siren a
stretched-out war and you're not the guy
and still you fit the description
because there is only one guy who is
always the guy fitting the description
get on the ground get on the ground now
I must have been speeding no you weren't
speeding I wasn't speeding you didn't do
anything wrong then why are you pulling
me over why am I pulled over put your
hands where they can be seen put your
hands in the air put your hands up then
you're stretched out on the hood then
cuffed get on the ground now each time
it begins in the same way it doesn't
begin the same way each time it begins
it's the same flashes a siren the
stretched out roar maybe because home
was a hood the officer could not afford
not that a reason was needed I was
pulled out of my vehicle a block from my
door handcuffed and pushed into the
police vehicles backseat
the officers knees pressing into my
collarbone the officers warm breath
vacating a face creased into the smile
of its own private joke each time it
begins in the same way it doesn't begin
the same way each time it begins it's
the same
go ahead and hit me fled my
lips and the officer did not need to hit
me the officer did not need anything
from me except the look on my face on
the drive across town
you can't drive yourself saying you're
not insane our motion is wearing you out
you're not the guy this is what it looks
like you know this is wrong this is not
what it looks like you need to be quiet
this is wrong you need to close your
mouth now this is what it looks like why
are you talking if you haven't done
anything wrong and you're not the guy
and still you fit the description
because there is only one guy who is
always the guy fitting the description
in a landscape drawn from an ocean bed
you can't drive yourself sane so angry
you can drive yourself sane the charge
the officer decided on was exhibition of
speed I was told after the
fingerprinting to stand naked I stood
naked it was only then I was instructed
to dress to leave to walk all those
miles back home and still you're not the
guy and still you fit the description
because there is only one guy who was
always the guy fitting the description
somebody said well how did he walk all
the way home in LA and in fact I asked
him that myself I said why did you walk
why didn't you call somebody and he said
he was so enraged in that particular
incident that he needed to walk I am I
was in the airport with my husband and
daughter and my husband is white and he
was you know inside his white mobility
and and a man came up to me and he
tapped me on the shoulder and he said
you need to come with me so I went with
him and my daughter turned around and
she saw me walking away and she said
where are you going and I said I'm being
racially profiled and the guy said to me
why are you saying that and I was like I
don't know I don't know why I'm saying
that what does a victorious or defeated
black woman's body in a historically
white space look like Serena and her big
sister Venus Williams brought to mind
Zora Neale Hurston's I feel most colored
when I'm thrown against a sharp white
background this appropriated line
stenciled on canvas by Glenn Ligon who
used plastic leather stencil smudging
oil sticks and graphite to transform the
words into abstractions seem to be ad
copy for some aspect of life for all
black bodies Hurston statement has been
played out on the big screen by Serena
and Venus they win sometimes they lose
sometimes they've been injured they've
been happy they've been sad booed
ignored booed my Delisi Indian Wells
which both sister have boycotted since
2001 they've been cheered and through it
all evident to all were those people who
were enraged they were there at all
graphite against a sharp white
background for years you attribute to
Serena Williams the kind of resilience
appropriate only to those who exist in
celluloid neither her father no her
mother nor her sister nor Jehovah her
God nor Nike Kemp could shield her
ultimately from people who felt her
black body didn't belong on their court
in their world
from the start met many made it clear
Serena would have done better struggling
to survive in the two dimensionality of
a millet painting rather than on their
tennis court better to put all that
strength to work in the fantasy of her
working the land rather than be caught
up in the turbulence of our ancient
dramas like a ship fighting a storm in a
Turner seascape this this image is by an
artist Nick Cave and he makes these
things called
sound suits and they cover you from head
to foot and when I first saw them
they're quite beautiful and intricate
and stunning but I wondered why did he
make them and it was one of those things
you know the kind of research we can do
now with the Internet is quite stunning
and it took me days to go back and back
and back and back you know how at the
bottom it always says see 20 more see 20
more and finally back in the 90s I found
an interview where he said I started
making these after the beating of Rodney
King because it was so clear that the
only problem for anti black races was
the color of people's skin
so he made these suits out of the trauma
comes the beauty perhaps but I still was
a little like huh interesting as a as a
recourse but then I read this book
called freedom dreams by Robin Kelly has
anyone read this book it's a fantastic
book and I recommend it on its own right
but the final chapter is on the surreal
and Kelly makes the point that systemic
racism is so deep and part of the
construction of all of us that the only
way out is a jump is literally to jump
and so then I began to think of Nick
Cave as a form of that jump the other
question I asked friends um was I you
know I have all these friends I'm very
popular a very nice person
you know I asked my friends to tell me
about a moment when they were in what
they can you know thought was an
intimate moment an ordinary moment a
boring interaction and suddenly racism
came in and changed the dynamics of that
interaction so that the encounter was
filled up by our history and oddly many
times the response was I can't think of
anything I'd be like really can't think
of anything mm-hmm
can't think of anything and then two
three days would
and the phone would ring and suddenly
not only could they think of something
they couldn't stop thinking of things
which meant that things had been put
away so that one could keep moving and
once that door was open I was open so
I'll read a few of those I won't keep
you too long because it is warm in here
you're in the dark in the car watching
the black tarred street being swallowed
by speed he tells you his dean is making
him hire a person of color when there
are so many great writers out there you
think maybe this is an experiment and
you're being tested or retro actively
insulted or you have done something that
communicates this is an OK conversation
to be having why do you feel comfortable
saying this to me you wish the light
would turn red or a police siren would
go off so you could slam on the brakes
slam into the car ahead of you fly
forward so quickly both your faces would
suddenly be exposed to the wind as usual
you drive straight through the moment
but the expecting backing off of what
was previously said it is not only that
confrontation is heady producing it is
also that you have a destination that
doesn't include acting like this moment
isn't inhabitable hasn't happened before
and the before isn't part of the now as
the night darkens and the time shortens
between where we are and where we are
going one of the things about these
stories as well is that every time
someone would tell me a story I would be
reminded of that moment in my life and
um about 20 years ago I got a job at her
at Barnard
I was about to say Harvard but maybe
maybe that's in the future and and after
I got this job at Barnard at Columbia a
poet in New York invited me to lunch and
I went to lunch and then she said to me
do you know that your job was supposed
to be my job but they needed to hire
somebody who was black and so I said I
didn't know that but what's interesting
about this is about a month ago
I was sitting next to this person at a
dinner and somebody at the dinner
brought up the piece I just read and she
turned to me the person and she said to
me you know I probably have done
something like that in the past like I
can tell you you have not probably
definitely you and your partner go to
see the film the house we live in you
ask a friend to pick up your child from
school on your way home your phone rings
your neighbor tells you he is standing
at the window watching a menacing black
guy casing both your homes the guy is
walking back and forth talking to
himself and seems disturbed you tell
your neighbor that your friend whom he
has met is babysitting he says no it's
not him he's met your friend and this
isn't that nice young man anyway he
wants you to know he's called the police
your partner calls your friend and ask
them if there's a guy walking back and
forth in front of your home your friend
says that if anyone were outside he
would see him because he is standing
outside you hear the sirens through the
speaker phone your friend is speaking to
your neighbor when you arrive
the four police cars are gone your
neighbor has apologized to your friend
and is now apologizing to you feeling
somewhat responsible for the actions of
your neighbor you clumsily tell your
friend that the next time he wants to
talk on the phone he should just go in
the back yard he looks at you a long
minute before saying he can speak on the
phone wherever he wants yes of course
you say yes of course and that that you
was me I I said that and I said it to
him because I was so you know we were
trapped in traffic on the 10th and the
police were coming and I thought oh my
god anything could happen and so when I
got home I'm just like I'm gonna hide
you away and it was you know a big
mistake a big mistake and I'm so glad he
said to me no no but that way that one
will limit one's own freedom in order to
get out of the way
of white supremacist thinking is another
way that the structure gets built into
the body so not my you know proudest
moment and I'm going to read one more
piece I I scoured this book for
something upbeat
and I found it it's here you probably
missed it but I found it
when the waitress hands your friend the
card she took from you you laugh and ask
what else her privilege you laugh and
ask what else her privilege gets her
oh my perfect life she answers then
you're both laughing so hard everyone in
the restaurant smiles so thank you very
much
I consented to answer questions I'm here
of my own free will
hi I'm interested in who and I don't
know if this is something you think
about when writing a book but if so who
you think ought to be the intended
audience for citizen citizens the title
is calling you I I think when I wrote
the book I was writing it for us and for
us and by us I mean I do mean us in this
room a kind of educated liberal maybe I
don't know
positioned mind that believes that
racism is outside that it's down south
that is it's positioned in our ancestry
but not in our own body like Ben Affleck
so so yes I this this was the intended
audience because I think one of the
things Barack Obama's presidency has
shown us that it has nothing to do with
achievement it has nothing to do with
exceptionalism it has nothing to do with
being articulate it has nothing to do
with
for one America it's here it's present
it's happening
as someone who's here accidentally but
mostly through the art world I was very
struck with how much visual work appears
this is my first time I thought I saw a
piece of Glenn leggins go by very
quickly do you have any thoughts about
word and image as as agencies or agents
because in the art world as you know
this is a subject of great travail I
think you used that word earlier or
somebody used a Jody Joey used it
earlier
Blake's the letter kills but logos the
word lives you sound like you might have
something to say on onward an image a
word an image um well first I'll answer
the question as to why the images are
there I because it is about image I
wanted the the reader to be engaged
visually because racism is about a
visual construction you can have a phone
call with somebody and the phone call
will seem quite innocent and then you
walk into the room and spoken or
unspoken is I didn't know you were black
because now that I know that things are
going to change you know so so I wanted
and I also feel like a visual artists
have engaged this discussion in ways
that are transparent Glenn liken use of
Zora Neale Hurston's I do not always
feel colored is is brilliant given the
way it fades out into the abstraction
and then for me becomes a metaphor for
the ways in which that understanding
comes invisible to the eye aiya sorry
but just blends work gets blacker and I
you used the word earlier police log
Jerry didn't yet well the the vernacular
term in the 19th and 20th century press
was police blotter and one always thinks
these words get blotted they get
absorbed and then either get whitened or
blackened exactly exactly that's a nice
a nice way to look at it I mean one of
the things that's really interesting to
me now is because of our phones we are
suddenly able to to unbel you know to to
bring back into focus that which has
become invisible so I know there's
legislation to try and prevent people
from filming police but I don't think
it's going to fly given the First
Amendment I mean it might fly on the
state level but I think if it gets to
the federal level it won't stand but
yeah um I don't want to get off on a
tangent but the there's another Glen leg
on this one also from the Million Man
March the way it again becomes a kind of
blotting away onto the surface of
reality
hi I'm wondering what you think about
the need for or the possibility for some
sort of redemption or reconciliation um
I was thinking about this because you
said for your the last part of your
reading just now that you pour it over
the book to find something um happy or
uplifting and you read something where
you know the white people in the room
could also share in the laughter and be
sort of like not not be left with this
bad feeling um and I was just speaking
to a friend who I'd lent this book to
over the weekend and she read it in
three hours because she said you know
it's just like a very exhausting
experience to read this book because it
reminds you of all those moments that
you've put away in the drawer just
enabled just to be able to keep moving
and to move forward and to survive um
and it brings back the exhaustion and
just the the draining Ness of all of
those moments that we go through in our
everyday lives as people of color um
so I'm wondering what you think about
and and she said like she kept reading
for three hours just to try to see if
there was going to be some sort of
redemption at the end and she didn't
feel like there really was and like a
lot of times it feels like with in white
supremacy there really isn't
um so I'm wondering what you think about
if there's a need for that if there's a
possibility for that and if you think
there is any in this book well I think I
think I don't know about redemption but
I think there is recognition and for me
that has some value because I I think
I'm a little bit exhausted by the sense
of I didn't know that would offend I
didn't intend to offend and then the
sort of white positioning of any
encounter that then pushes back
on the offends means that now whiteness
is the victim of your anger so I thought
it might be nice if we went forward with
intention so if you know if you wish to
insult me do it with intention so that
when it gets called out we don't have
the normal I was just joking
why don't you develop a sense of humor
why are you so sensitive so in that
sense yes recognition not as redemptive
but as consciousness holding that being
using intention Don Imus maybe he said
what he intended you know so so in that
sense in that but redemption I was never
worried I was thinking of in this I mean
it was a difficult book to end because
because of that very thing you I didn't
want to create a false sense of any kind
of resolution around something that is
present everyday that piece that I read
about the the card it was a moment that
happened I was with a friend of mine and
for both of us it was the enactment the
blatant erasure of me at that table the
insistence that I did not take the card
from her and I will not return the card
to her was so performative in a way that
it did amuse both of us we did start
laughing and we laughed so much
that everybody else in the restaurant
started laughing a little bit too I mean
they didn't know why they were laughing
but and so it wasn't really put out
there as laughter for white people but
laughter around the idiocy of the moment
that I think we all share in white or
black or Asian or you know that there is
a sense of recognition that there is
nothing to do but laugh at it in a sense
because it is so ridiculous oh yeah hi
I just wanted to say that um when you
were talking about your friend the
lawyer who lived across from Paul Newman
mm-hmm I'm pretty sensitive to race
product of the boston public school
system in the era of busing and my
family is of mixed race and um it was
interesting when you said you were in
Southern California and your friend was
a lawyer and he lived across from Paul
Newman I pictured a white man it wasn't
until you said and his wife is white
that I realized he wasn't and that to me
says this is a major issue because this
always happens and yeah you know I mean
it really is I'm so glad that you wrote
this because I really do think it is for
everyone and I wanted to say that out
loud because I'm sure that there are a
lot of other bodies in this room that
thought the same thing and maybe didn't
even get it at that point that I did but
you know it may die it's just so
alarming to me how deeply as you said
that it's rooted in our minds and my
bodies and it's just there and there's
not really it's step for making that
jump like you said that we can really
escape
and I hope that it touches a lot of
people or we begin to call ourselves out
as you just did I mean the there's a
book found fun no black skin white masks
in which he talks about the ways in
which the black body internalizes the
racist structures that it lives within
and so the self-hatred begins to grow
inside the black community so that
things or in communities of any other so
you know Native Americans everyone else
also and so you begin to value your
light-skinned child over your darker
skinned child you begin to question the
name of somebody versus the name of
someone else I had a really interesting
moment because I was invited to read or
I didn't really read for them I was
invited to go to this class I guess it
was a workshop for teachers in the
public schools and many of these women
were white and they had dedicated their
lives to teaching in the public schools
and I asked them to write down a moment
when they found themselves committing a
microaggression that surprised them and
there were 12 women in the room seven of
them wrote down the same thing
independently and what they said was I
will have a student of color I will have
that student for four years that student
will have done excellent work for four
years they would get great grades then
they get into an institution like this
one and I find myself saying to them
what a surprise
and that moment of surprise for all of
them as much as they have invested their
time and energy in educating these young
people for the white student it was like
you go girl
for the black Hispanic what a surprise
and one of the women said you know I
just don't understand how I could know
that this kid has worked hard comes here
ready to go and I have worked with them
for the last four years and I still see
them as someone not up to it where is
that coming from
one more question
hi thanks I think this connects a little
bit to what you were just saying I was
thinking a little bit about how to take
responsibility as a white person without
taking over and what I was thinking is
as thinking of your scene in the car
worth person is saying I have to hire a
person of color when there's so many
talented writers out there and I was
thinking if I was in the car I would
feel very comfortable snapping that
person's head off in an instant because
it wouldn't impact me in the same way
I'd be in a different position but if I
did that that would also impact you if
you were my friend and so I was
wondering I know you don't have an
answer to this but what your thoughts
are on speaking out against racism but
not trying to speak for somebody else to
speak to your own concerns but not
trying to speak for your friend of color
does that make sense
that makes sense and the thing you
should know about that piece that was a
white woman in that car yeah and and she
felt that suddenly she was being asked
to be an alliance with this racist
construction and when she told me the
story she said what did I do to suggest
that it was okay
what did what did I do to implicate
myself in that and I think I think the
other thing about your question is it's
not I think that when you speak out
you're not speaking out for anybody else
you're speaking out for yourself do you
want to be in the company of this your
you know it's not for me that you do it
you're doing it for you and that might
be part of the problem that there is
still this perception that the
institution of racism only affects
people of color and because of perceived
mobility of whiteness it really isn't
your problem I mean if it stinks it
stinks
thank you thank you
you